tears of the Kingdom has finally arrived
and is shaped up to be one of the most
mind-blowing games I've ever played
during my time with the game I'm willing
to share a couple Secrets I've learned
along the way and all of these are
achievable even before leaving the
beginning area the great Sky Islands so
here are 14 spoiler friendly things I
wish I knew while playing tears of the
Kingdom
you'll get an item called zonai charges
right off the bat in the beginning of
the game its main function is to act as
currency to then throw into the Kata
machine to get some Nifty Zone and
machine parts useful for building things
to help navigate the world but it also
has a secondary function of refilling
your zonai battery charge if you're low
cool thing is this is never wasted
because using this while already at full
charge gives you a bar of overcharge
great for getting ready for a long trip
that requires lots of energy torches are
fairly rare in this game that's because
there's another more available option
for you fusing wood to a metal weapon
this also never burns out just like a
reg regular torch so you can carry your
fire whenever you need for as long as
you want and even keep you warm while
Mobile in a pinch if you played breath
of the wild one nice trick for gaining
height you might remember is to throw
four bundles of wood on the floor and
light them for a decent updraft thing is
there's something else you can use for
updrafts that worked in breath of the
wild too spicy peppers but this time
it's different spicy peppers create a
much more powerful updraft gaining
almost as much height as ravali scale
while you don't have the pear glider
right in the beginning of the game this
trick will soon come in handy for many
players once they do and this helps them
Traverse the world much much easier
there's a new ability in Link's Arsenal
that will definitely come in handy by
readying to throw with your weapon with
r then pressing up on the d-pad you can
now select any material to forcefully
throw Elemental choo choos while charged
up fires up a large explosion that can
hurt pretty bad if you're up close
poking at it with a long stick is the
best option or hitting them then back
flipping as soon as possible there's
also another option throw literally
anything at it even wood or flowers and
set off the explosion to kill it from a
safe distance
fusing in general is something you
should really experiment with when you
get it just start mixing things together
the whole process is extremely fun while
some combinations are harmless fun
there's a couple fuse options that will
not work well or even completely
backfire
sales attached to Spears unlike swinging
weapons like one or two-handed weapons
won't do anything because the stabbing
motion doesn't create wind at this angle
so large wooden boards or Sails are best
saved for weapons that are not Spears
while various explosions are small
enough to not affect link when fused to
a weapon choo choo jellies even on long
range weapons such as a spear can reach
you on impact and hurt you pretty badly
you also might have come across a ruby
while mining in the caves these attach
to handheld weapons gives you a Nifty
Elemental want but throwing them or
shooting them is a very dangerous thing
to do as the explosion these give off
are ginormous and more often than not
you'll be blown up along with your foes
[Applause]
a quick tip that everyone should know is
when powering on zonai devices with your
weapon it doesn't take any durability so
go ahead and use any handheld weapon
don't waste your durability on any other
option
in the beginning of the game your
inventory isn't too bad but by the time
you leave the sky islands and definitely
later on your inventory starts to get
pretty packed with tools to help
navigate around this you can sort by
type fuse attack power and by most used
most used is the most useful but isn't
really perfect because some items you
want aren't as close to the front of the
menu as you'd like if you want to
capitalize on this mechanic you can
randomly throw the material multiple
times onto the ground to make it more
used to put it closer to the beginning
of the list only problem is this is very
very wasteful with items that get
destroyed when throwing so just keep
this problem in mind as you play the
game and get some practice in navigating
the materials and other menus Nintendo
please just make a manual favoriting
system this is insane
when you reach the snowy area of the
great Sky Islands there's something you
should always be on the lookout for
icicles these can be shot down then
fused to your weapon not only is it a
fairly strong attachment it's actually a
freezing attachment which allows
follow-up attacks to do much more damage
making combat just a bit easier
on top of that using the ice elements on
a body of water will create handy ice
blocks the possibilities of this can be
pretty interesting such as obviously
using this as a boat or a bridge
by using fuse on it just like the icicle
will make for a handy ice weapon
better than that though slap the ice you
just made onto your Shield jump then
press ZL and a together in midair to
Shield Surf and now you have a higher
durability and more slippery surfboard
that's protected by the ice block this
can really speed up your travel going
downhill when you're in a pinch and you
don't want to damage your Shield too
badly just keep in mind that while in
direct sun or warmer weather this stuff
will start to melt off talking about
fusing to your Shield you can find some
bomb flowers early on while yes they are
obviously great to use as makeshift bomb
arrows try slapping them on the shield
instead yes you can blow up incoming
enemy attacks but even better Shield
surf with the bomb attached Shield jump
launching is insanely useful in combat
and once you learn this you might want
to try out some more flashy versions to
style on your enemies this might invoke
some Michael Bay vibes
another easy way to gain bullet time is
by using the glider you use to cross the
Gap back to the Temple of time if
attached to your shield and shield
jumping you'll gain extra height enough
to use bullet time mid-air this means
you can pretty much get bullet time
whenever you want
early in the game you get a chance to
catch a ride on a glider but there's no
way to directly control it a quick tip
is depending on where you're standing on
the glider the glider will tilt in that
direction giving you semi controls while
you're flying through the air I
recommend holding ZL while doing this to
give you more precise control because
accidentally falling off while doing
this is totally possible out of the four
main abilities link gets fuse is usually
used for combat and recall Ultra hand
and Ascent are mostly used for puzzling
and navigation Ultra hand gives you the
ability to lift and put things together
recall rewind things to a previous
location and Ascend gives you the
ability to climb through solid objects
but what if I told you that these things
could be used in combination with each
other at the same time what if I wanted
to pass this log up to a platform that's
too high well just lift up the log near
the platform go up there then recall it
then use ultra hand on the recalling
item mid time reverse to accomplish your
goal or even further combine all three
by lifting a rock with ultra hand for a
second recalling then ascending into the
Rock You lifted up
or even further knock down a bunch of
trees and fuse them into a massive hole
turn it upright with ultra hand recall
it then Ascend through the entire
Contraption to gain massive height
this honestly is just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to possibilities
you have in the game so once you get a
handle on the basics start looking at
the world in a different way and give
all of your what if possibilities a try
many of your ideas will actually work
hopefully some of these tips will help
you in your journey in tears of the
Kingdom if you found this video helpful
give us a like and we'll have even more
interesting tidbits in the future with
things you didn't know about tears of
the Kingdom so stay with us here on
Gamespot
foreign
[Music]